and today's featured presenters as bill
Burnett bill is an adjunct professor of
mechanical engineering and the executive
director of the design program at
Stanford University he directs the
undergraduate and graduate programs in
design and teaches at the d.school Phil
recetas Bachelors of Science and Master
of Science and product design at
Stanford and has worked in startups and
fortune 100 companies including seven
years at Apple designing award-winning
laptops in a number of years in the toy
industry designing Star Wars action
figures
he holds a number of mechanical and
design patents and design awards and in
addition to his duties at Stanford he is
on the board of laws but socially
responsible fashion startup and advises
several other startup companies and now
I'd like to turn the floor over to go
thank you very much let's see looks
easily good there we go there's the
first flight so today we're going to
talk about this idea of called we call
design your life which is sort of an
interesting sort of grand claim can
people actually use this I'm thinking to
design their lives for those of you who
are familiar I'm sure many of you are
with the Design Thinking ideas the
diagram we have for our process says you
know design thinking process starts with
empathy for users so we're kind of come
up with a new kind of mobile phone or a
new application for dieting or something
we talk to users we figure out what they
really need
we typically redefine and reframe the
problem a bunch of times until we're
sure we've got it right
lots of ideas in the ideation phase and
then we build and test prototype and
test our way forward and that's the
context just that's the way Design
Thinking works it's a very iterative and
generative process companies like IBM
and Apple and people you know are using
this process to innovate products so the
the you know the kind of collection
becomes Jesus this is a human centered
problem-solving approach can we apply
Design Thinking to this wicked problem
of designing maybe your job or
redesigning your career and potentially
even adjusting the issue of how do I
have a meaningful life and
about ten years ago my co-founder of the
design your life lab to be life lab at
Stanford Dave Evans and I sort of
started a conversation about this idea
could you've applied design thinking to
the wicked problem wicked problems a
technical term so problems that are
open-ended and ade they're hard to solve
and as soon as you solve them new
problems emerge could you subviews
design thinking to work on things like
having a meaningful life and it really
gets back to the question that we get
asked in office hours and we get asked
and we're doing workshops and seminars
it's the one question that doesn't ever
seem to go away and that's what do I
want to be when I grow up question now
if we were alive I that should all raise
your hands if you've ever been asked
this question I think a hundred percent
of all humans on the planet and I've
every culture I've done this workshop in
and in Portugal and Spain and Italy and
in Taiwan and Korea and China every said
yeah people always asking is what I want
to be when I grow up and sometimes I ask
myself that question so here's our first
reframe and Design Thinking is big on
coming up with a new way of looking at
the problem we call it reframe we don't
ever want you to grow up at least if
growing that means losing that childlike
curiosity about that world that hunger
to learn new things so we reframe this
problem as what do I want to grow into
as I explore the rest of my life and
we've been doing do our workshops based
on the book that came out in September
all over the country and we haven't yet
to meet anyone we have in the very first
workshop we did for the Stanford Alumni
Association in New York we had a woman
sitting front and center in a room of
350 alums she was from the class of 1950
she was 80 some years old and she taught
the rest of her life was going to be
very very interesting so we have never
met anybody who doesn't think that it
would be worth having some tools and
ideas about how to explore this growing
into the rest of their lives so that's
our reframe and you know we've been
teaching this class at Stanford since
2006 so a little more than 10 years and
we started out with just a classical
designing your ice we started I'm going
to class for chest mine the kids in my
major the design students called the
designers voice but that very quickly
became a general class for everyone at
the university engineers not engineers
science majors history majors people
from the drama department from the art
department people from computer science
all the students across the board and we
have a class for seniors called
designing your life because they're the
ones that with the the kind of the
biggest pain point they're about to
launch into the world and they've never
been anything but a student before then
we were asked to do a classic refreshed
and compression so ever designing your
Stanford profession we say don't do
don't do Stanford like you did high
school it's a much bigger experience and
you don't want to be so ballistic you
don't just pick a major and go you know
because that's not utilizing Stanford
for all of the resources that it has and
then we also do with classical design
professionals for masters students and
PhD students who are thinking about you
know really want to go into academic
surgery I want to do a career in
industry and the same ideas and tools
apply to all of these people except
slightly different framing questions
because there are different stages in
their lives we also do this off campus
with mid-career professionals and and we
just the director of our lab the
mentoring director our lab Kathy Davis
is designing your life for women weekend
down is Asilomar on the coast here in
the area so there's lots and lots of
interest in this stuff and we've
actually measured the results around
whether or not taking the class you know
has an impact on people and I got this
old poster this is a very busy slide I
apologize but it's what it's normally a
big you know sort of you know three foot
by two foot poster given at a conference
and this was the work of Lindsay OE
she'd was a PhD candidate studying the
class and one of the things she did was
she studied people who took the class
there's a random group of students who
were her controls and group of students
who wanted to take the class that
couldn't get in who just had intention
but didn't have the actual intervention
of the class the class outcomes were
you're looking at little yellow box in
the middle the confidence to explore
careers and make good decisions went way
up the belief in these career myths what
I'll call dysfunctional beliefs and I'll
talk about those in a second went way
down and the ability to identify and
achieve
specific occupational goals went way up
and it's that little chart on the far
right there with the red green and blue
bars as an indication people grew in
their flexibility to have new ideas and
in their creativity to imagine new
possible futures so it's pretty clear
that if you just take the class or in
this case maybe read the book that you
can have you know a higher confidence
that you can choose well as you move
forward in your career that you will be
more inventive and creative if you
practice the techniques taught in in the
class and that was really kind of nice
to hear this you know on a scientific
basis with a controlled study we could
have that kind of impact you know on a
student's outcome part of that was we
get rid of what psychologists call
dysfunctional beliefs the first one we
try to blow up is this belief that the
organizing question for your life is
what your passion again if we were
allowed I'd say how many people have
been asked this question in the last
month or two and I think experiences any
evidence 9/10 of you would say oh yeah
this question comes up all the time it's
a terrible question we think for a
couple of reasons and here's the data on
it now I'm not I'm not going to say that
if you if you knew at age five you
wanted to be a ballerina and you are now
dancing you know with the New York
ballet company awesome that you've found
your passion early and you track to it
and you achieved it but the data says
that only colors have a population can
actually answer this question bill Damon
wrote a fantastic look past the purpose
bill is the head of the center for the
study of adolescents here at Stanford
and top researcher in the field of
careers purpose meaning he did a pretty
extensive study and very few people you
know one out of five can say I know what
I want to do and I'm kind of going for
it everybody else either has many things
that they're interested in or not know
one things that rises to whatever the
level of passion is so we're
uncomfortable with the technique that
says okay you come to the front of the
line and I say what's your passion you
said I don't know and until they go back
of the line when you figure it out come
back and I'll work with you
that's just it just doesn't seem fair
and people who people come to us all the
time and say you know I should have had
I should have identified
action by now but I don't have one and
they feel like they've done something
wrong and the data is you're not Ron you
normal so don't worry about this
question
tell Newport wrote a book called be so
good they can't ignore you or something
to that effect and in which he tracks
the same thing and he says look passion
is the outcome of working hard in a
field that you love and discovering that
it is truly your calling it's an end
point it's not a starting point so if
you can take one thing away from the
talk today
blow up this belief that you have to
have a passion it's not true second
assumption belief is what you should be
knitting you should know you're going to
buy now and if you're not you're late
and and and I when I grew up that was 25
by 25 year supposed to have a sort of
primary relationship you know in the
oven and ready to go and you were
supposed to have a job that was the
thing you were going to do for the rest
of your life and if you didn't have it
by 25 you were like there's something
wrong with you now my students should
probably say 30 but the point is it's a
ridiculous question it's going to be
more than one of you in there anyway
you're going to have multiple careers
you can't be late because you have
worked late to which kirillov the second
one the third one the first one is often
exploratory in nature and so the fact
that you're trying lots of things is the
new normal there's no such thing as
being late the third one you know which
which probably is the most dysfunctional
one is that you should be optimizing the
very best version of you there is one
singular version of you apply to this
question and you should find it and if
you don't find it then you are not
actually having the best possible life
and you are settling for something less
than that and a wrench this with lots of
people touch you in in our little many
workshops they're like no no I pick
something but it's really not what I
wanted but I can't change and it's not
the best and we're like well well one
you can't change - it's never too late
and three this idea of best imply some
singular path I mean look all of us if
we looked backwards in our lives and we
asked you to honestly tell me how did
you get here how did you get to the
thing you're doing today
you would have to argue that some of it
was choice I mean some good choices
along the way some of it was hate some
opportunities showed up I put myself in
a context where those opportunities
might happen and then and that was great
and a bunch of it is luck you know I'll
tell you my story I ended up a professor
at Stanford enough I never plan to do
that I grew up in the East Coast in
Boston just back there recently and
reminded that reminded me that everybody
thought I was going to go to Harvard or
Yale and when the letter for Stanford
came and I didn't even know that what
Stanford really was this was a long time
ago before you know the internet and
famous colleges good letter from
Stanford came and I picked it so I could
get as far away from my parents as
possible when I went to college that was
my sole criteria I came here as a
physics major I washed out of physics in
about two quarters and then decided I'd
invent my own major physics and art
because I was always an artist when I
went to declare that major I discovered
that this campus has the one singular
program in the entire academic world
called product design which combined
physics our psychology anthropology and
a bunch of other things that I was
deeply interested in it was dumb luck
that I ended here had to kinda Harvard
I'd been a lawyer I always wanted to be
a lawyer and never wanted to be an
engineer that said I mean some good
choices and I put myself in the context
where those traces could get realized
there was no one best version there's an
old expression in business you know good
is the enemy a better better skinny at
best you should always try to do your
best
Dave reframes that as the unavailable
best is the enemy of all the available
betters there's so many other ways that
you can experience you know a life it's
meaningful and a career that is moving
in the direction that it makes sense to
you that has a purpose but getting rid
of this notion that if you don't have
the right one or the best one or the
only one if you're somehow settling
which is a terrible feeling getting rid
of this mission sense to release people
from a lot of inaction and start them
towards yourself in the class we have a
we kind of support the Design Thinking
model with two things we talked all
about meaning the meaning making less
layer in all the research we did just
create the class we do a lot of research
because their psychology literature and
generally in the literature of healthy
people and that what makes healthy
people happy and also litter the South
the literature and research on the
students themselves went and did lots of
me finding everybody says the goal of
this experience of those experience with
life is to do something meaningful and
what my life to have a purpose I'm going
to know what it was for so we have a
meaning-making layer we call the point
of view the work view in the world view
and we have all these assignments around
that layer and then we have what we call
you know the Design Thinking piece where
we teach brainstorming and mind mapping
and reframing and all the mindsets of a
designer and and then we have the
discovery and support layer where we
talked about the practices you have to
have so that you are ready to make their
decisions how do you use a certain
things how do you know and make
decisions about things with something
other than just logic emotional
intelligence kinesthetic intelligence
other ways of knowing we talked about
the importance of mentors in community
because you can't do this by yourself we
encourage people to work through the
book in design teams and we're tracking
over 400 teams now that are doing that
it's like a book club or design Club you
have to do this together so this is kind
of a visual syllabus if you will of the
class I don't have time to do all of
these things but I want to touch on it
unti that I think are kind of fun and
important what is this idea of flow a
guy named Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi
who's about to pronounce name in
psychology colleague of Martin Seligman
wrote a book called flows of psychology
of optimal experience and you've all
been in state to flow you might call it
something to hit the zone if you were an
athlete you know or just in the moment
if you if you like that training but
it's the thing while you're doing
something you're working on something
time stands still you're completely
involved in the thing you have a sense
of energy he calls it a sense of ecstasy
about that there's some inner clarity
about the purpose of the thing you're
doing and people experiences sort of a
timeless you know serene moment pretty
high high things she has this as a model
what he calls the flow zone where the
flow channel where
but the challenge that you're facing is
is popping up so it's really challenging
your skills but it's not so challenging
that you you moved over into anxiety or
distress that this is too hard I'm not
doing it well and it's not so easy that
you're getting bored to task so you're
allowed to hyper focus and pushing your
skill just to the edge of the limit of
the task you're doing now
you know athletes will do that in a
moment in athletics where they just feel
like they're totally connected to the
team or to the moment or to the new
where the ball is going to be scientists
experienced this by just going into the
lab and writing things on a whiteboard
and just kind of not even exhausting
themselves which is just being
completely inside the problem-solving
moment I have moments of this one I'm
teaching I've moments of this during you
know conversations and office hours but
it can also have these some very simple
moments like I like to cook and so
chopping and chopping onions and lemmy's
on plots for the meal getting everything
prepped and ready
that's a flow moment for me because I
feel confident in the kitchen and I'm
trying new things online so if you don't
want to may have a wonderful meal so our
idea about this is that you should be
finding yourself in your career in your
life in moments of flow every week if
you're not finding that happened it was
one of two things that are possible from
the literature and from Mihaly
Csikszentmihalyi work one is you're not
noticing a lot of our lives are so busy
now we're doing so much so we test on
those stuff and so keeping a journal
which is one of the you know principal
practices we teach our students is a
good way of just bringing things to your
attention now there's two ways of
noticing one way of just being in the
moment there's a lot of mindfulness
stuff in the world right now I think
that's kind of cool
and then the other way of noticing is in
retrospect going back at the end of your
day then journaling about you know is
there any time where I felt a sense of
flow
or even a slow a preliminary flow moment
maybe was possible other times during
the day where things that were working
for me very well and things that weren't
working and by keeping a journal what
the psychologist notices once you start
noticing taking the time to notice in
retrospect certain behaviors or certain
moves if you are in you will reinforce
your ability to one notice those moods
and they will happen more frequently and
there's that you know there's an old
saying work isn't supposed to be fun
that's why they call it work we totally
disagree since work is the thing you're
going to be doing 40 or 50 hours a week
in addition to everything else you do
it's one of the dominant activities and
behaviors of your of your day and your
week and so you should be enjoying it
now there's some startling statistics
around this Gallup does a poll every
couple years and something like 70% of
the people say they're deeply disengaged
from the work they do and another 15%
said it just disengaged so we'll say
eighty-five percent of American workers
get up on Monday morning and say not
really wanna go to work doesn't mean
anything to me
this is startling in kind of his
dysfunction you don't want to be in that
eighty-five percent so one of the ways
to notice that the work you're doing has
some meaning is that it creates these
flow States
so flow journal is our part sort of
first recommendation the other thing
about about flow is it's about you know
it's about where your energy is going to
a large extent our experience of the
world is sort of what's going on in our
head that part of your head that's
always talking to you is a part of your
head that's talking to you saying hey
this is a really fun experience or hey
I'm really learning a lot this is really
interesting
then you're experiencing your day or
that moment as meaningful if the talking
in your head is I don't know what I'm
doing this for this I have no context
for this this isn't interesting then
that's your reality and so we developed
a little tool that's been pretty
successful with students and
and with mid-career people and everybody
a lot of people talk about time
management let's make if I just manage
my week better you know my time
management is the important stuff is not
the urgent stuff all that stuff's fine
but what we find is that it's a little
bit cumbersome to keep track of time and
time management system and really what
you're actually trying to what we think
you're actually trying to keep track of
it is not so much to how many hours that
I spend on tasks a or B but how did I
feel about it
and so we reframed the time management
thing to energy management so the way
you do this to take some take some
things from your float journal for the
week or just take your take your Google
Calendar or whatever you've got take it
out write down all of the repetitive
meetings activities whatever that you're
doing during the week and not just let's
just work things like you know I got the
budget meeting I got this look at that
but all I take my kids to soccer games
and I cooked a little eating one that
weekend any of your regular engagements
and then chart those engagements each to
each and each specific engagement and
put them in order of you know the game
of the week end of the week and check
them in terms of like how energetic are
those activities and I don't mean this
in a sort of you know California New Age
energy thing I'm just saying you know
there's some stuff you do and when you
do it you're done you're just as an
energetic or more energetic when you
started it kind of feeds you it gives
you energy it feels purposeful there's
other stuff you do then you leave leave
the task and you're drained you're
exhausted or you're tired or you're
bored those are negative energy tasks so
take those things and put them on a
chart I'll show you what the chart looks
like and I just charted my week it's
just as an example for you to use here's
my week so to start out the beginning of
the thing that that that long tall thing
that says flow next to it should have
art class somehow that got moved off the
slide but it's over there art classes
the first thing I do on Monday next to
high-energy activity I have budget
meetings I'm the executive director of
our program have to have a budget
meeting every week it's kind of a boring
meeting that feel a little bummed out
when I'm done I love my office hours
those are lots of fun
that's a high-energy activity I love
talking to my students the faculty
meeting is a funny one like when I
should with the faculty who are doing
the robotic cars here at Stanford and
tell a robotic medicine and amazing K
through 12 program at the b-school and
other things and when we're talking
about that stuff the faculty meetings
are like this incredible intellectual
salon and I love them
then every once in a while we'll have a
25-minute conversation and who forgot to
write down how many copies they made on
the copier and now the copier tally is
out of order and I'm thinking this is
the dumbest thing we can be talking
about it that's smartest people in the
world Sarah each other and like I'm just
like here's 20 bucks and you know zero
the callee will start again I don't care
so sometimes those are dumb meetings I
love walking around the campus that's
always fun for my a little bit of
physical health teaching is fun
I don't like housecleaning I love date
night with my wife and this was the
weird one master's coaching I should
like my master students where we
admitted them and they're my favorite
students and I coached them on their on
their thesis projects and that wasn't
working very well so look at you do your
chart like that and you're looking for
two things you're looking for motive
flow I've identified two office hours in
math class math class Texas 6:30 we're
doing figure drawing sometimes by 9:30 I
look up and I'm like why's the model
coming off the stage are we done you
know what's what's going ahead so so
much fun
same thing with working with my students
like I often go well with and time in my
office hours because they just think the
conversation with the students is so
interesting and their growth and
development is so interesting and that's
why I'm here so those are amazing
masters cooking was a little bit odd and
it didn't really work for me and and so
I came up with some strategies to fix
that and I'll show you those in a second
but just one one little set ground this
energy thing if you really want to talk
about energy in true engineering terms
the human body runs on 2,000 calories a
day 2,000 kilocalories a day of energy
that's how much food you eat and we
converted at some level of efficiency
into the energy that runs your body so
you would imagine energy is distributed
over the body you know sort of pro-rata
you know the size of the organs
it's not the human brain which is only
about two or three percent of the body
consumes 500 calories a day consumes 25%
of all the energy then you that you run
on and so what's really clear is that
what you know and if it consumed it any
more than that's probably the rest of
the body consumption so we assumed
evolutionarily it's evolved to take as
much energy as it can but know more then
we'll be imbalanced but since it's so
disproportionate to the size and the
weight of the organ itself it must be
important right and so this idea that
what we actually spend our attention on
what we attend to pay attention to this
meeting or paying attention to something
or paying attention to worrying we're
paying attention to negative thoughts
that is what the energy of your brain
gets spent on and so you want to be very
aware of where are the positive and
negative loads on that attention because
that changes your perception of how your
day's going and I'm not talking about
just thinking happy thoughts I'm just
talking about spending being mindful of
what you pay attention to what you
talked about in your head and in the
world because that is truly kind of how
you represent reality to you so in the
engagement energy tool you just notice
what's consuming lots of your energies
what's generating mortgages what's
what's what's generative in the energy
space and then that simple chart you can
use to redistribute to redefine your
engagements like when I notice flow
states that double down on those and I'm
actually going back to the studio
tonight to do some weird run because my
wife's out of town
and when I notice a negative thing I try
to either fix it or understand it so in
the case of persons you notice that was
you know the budget meeting is not that
positive but I'm the executive director
I have to do but just I can't say I'm
not going to do budgets sometimes that
actually the master stroke is to just
say I'm going to stop doing that task
but that's not always possible so what I
do now is I take my master's coaching
and I put it between office hours and my
workout so I'm excusing alone my my
budget meeting being office hours and
workout and therefore by surrounding a
lot of interesting to high energy things
I negate its influence and in the week
I feel very positive that the week was
useful and the master's coaching thing I
realized I was doing the coaching in our
studio is called the lot it's a great
place but it's very messy and I couldn't
get the focus and attention I wanted in
that place so I didn't want to move it
to my office because then we're in the
professor's office and the conversation
will be natural so I moved it through
the terrace outside the coffee house so
now I'm by the students a cup of coffee
and we have our engagement there and
just by changing the place I totally
change the way the energy shows up for
me and now it's a big positive I'm sure
it's a much more positive experience for
the students as well because I'm more
focused and more attentive so you can
change place you can change sequence you
can change a number of different things
in our in the book and in the class we
have a thing for the a e i o u method
you can change activities you can change
engagements you can change locations
that kind of thing let's take a look at
that but it's a really simple tool even
just to bring to awareness what it is
you're paying attention to and then the
last violent act about is this notion of
a gravity problem I'm sure you have a
friend not you but a friend who's been
good even going to copy with her lunch
with for the last couple years and they
say things like oh my boss sucks or I
don't like my partner my job is terrible
or something they have a whole litany of
problems and every time you get together
with them it's the same problems and so
where there's a class of problems in the
world we call gravity problems because
you can't actually solve them they're
not solvable and when you run across a
problem that's not solvable so
continuing to act on it is it just
causes a huge sense of disappointment
and defeat
David might go out to David say you
can't solve a problem you're not willing
to have so the first step in identifying
whether it's a gravity problem is really
to identify is this a problem that's not
even savile because if it's not
actionable in any way it's just a
circumstance like gravity davis dealing
with someone who was working in a
family-run court
raishin the name of the corporation was
the last name of the family and he was
complaining on vice-president of
marketing that I can never become the
president of the company because I
remember the family and my name is not
on the door and they've said you're
absolutely right you can never become
the president of this company now what
do you want to do about that do you want
it is that problem you want to try to
solve or is that just something you want
to complain about because if it's just
complaining it's a gravity problem now
we're not saying you can't fight city
hall if you decide to fight City Hall
and you decide to fight systemic racism
beautiful besides as a woman you know
that your mission is going to be to end
sexism in the office then it's no longer
a gravity problem because it's a problem
you're willing to take on a problem
you're willing to solve but if you just
want to work and you just want to be
happy and you just want to get stuff
done the only the first step in gravity
promises accept and I'm not suggesting
that you're accept systemic racism or
anything like that you just say okay
this is a system that I have to deal
with in the world and now it's reify
have to decide how I want to deal with
it so be careful with gravity problems
because we see people sucked into these
black holes over and over again and it
really keeps them stuck in their lives
and the one thing we hear in all the
workshops is that once you recognize
what a gravity problem is you learn how
to reframe problems to work on them in a
more effective manner and you start
looking at things like energy and
engagement you can really up the quality
of the experience of your week and of
your job in of your life career
partnerships in a significant way so we
want to talk about the little I
mentioned so that actually doesn't
excite I meant to do the Builder did the
solution to gravity problems of course
is to start with the first step and
actually we add accept in the in the
diagram of design thinking with respect
to your life we add the accept step
first
look it's really simple when we've
really sat down 7 8 10 years ago to
design this I said I think design
thinking can be applied to the problem
of
of an individual and a life rather than
the problem of designing a new song
and so we went looking to see if that
were true because I didn't want to force
the analogy so in this case you will
first of all you start with except I'm a
my working on something I'm willing to
work on it is there is there a something
in my life what is their need in my life
that I need to satisfy or solve when we
teach this idea of need finding of using
empathy to go out and understand what
people need we see we say in the need is
a gap between what you what you want and
the use or usability or the meaning of
the thing you know that you're trying to
get just so there's some kind of a gap
so we noticed with students and with
other people who are thinking about
their lives the gap was this meaning gap
I'm doing stuff I'm working I have jobs
I don't know what it adds up to and
there's no structure in the world that's
going to tell me that I'm going to have
to figure it out for myself so all the
original ethnography we did on this
problem with our students and with me
through people and with on corporate
people people who are retiring and then
what they split the people are retiring
earlier now there it's certainly
retiring healthier now so they've got 10
or 20 years of productive productive
life in them after they retire and they
go well I want to do something with this
stuff but I don't know how to get to the
thing that's meaningful the thing that
gives me some kind of purpose but the
reason I get up on Monday morning you
say I'm really looking forward to going
into work rather than oh my god do I
have to spend another week doing that
stuff so the idea that we could turn
empathy on ourselves so we could have
empathy for our own gaps for our own
spaces between what we want and this
idea of meaning and that we could also
turn our empathy on the world what is
the world you need from me Dave will say
when your greatest when your greatest
gift you know is given to the world in a
way where the world really wants it then
you have the perfect match right and
just because I'm passionate about
something doesn't mean the world wants
to pay me for it just because I'm
excited about something doesn't mean
that the world is excited
what I want and so one of the things we
try to we try to see is would it be
possible to use empathy for ourselves in
empathy for the world to close this gap
one meaning to do that we realize well
there's gravity problems as things that
keep people stuck we're going to have to
reframe all of this stuff but that's
perfect for the defined part of the
problem and then we know that if you
have lots and lots of ideas you're going
to have better things to choose from
there's tons and tons of data so we
evolved this idea that's not one of you
there's at least three we're going to
id8 on three versions of our life number
one we're going to ID eight and mind map
and brainstorm and do those well teach
you the way designers do those that
they're highly productive and outcome
driven activities not just oh we have a
lot of ideas and now I don't know what
to do with them
so we knew we could do that and then
fundamentally since you're trying to
create the future of you and the future
is unknowable you don't know if the
thing you want to do will be successful
you don't know if you even really want
to do it and this notion that you had to
pick something go all-in and then if it
didn't work
oh well you didn't get the best outcome
just seem like that's not the way
designers approach the problem and I was
at Apple a long time ago when we went to
the first laptops so I wasn't it when
they were doing the phone but if you
read about and see Steve Jobs biography
by Walter Isaacson if you read about the
story of the phone you know they they
prototype the phone hundreds of times
and they showed it to Steve three times
and three times he twice he turned it
down and the third time he said it was
good enough so this notion that they
were going to work on one singular
version it's just not the way designers
work they were working on multiple ideas
for the interaction the interface the
screen you know the original one didn't
have a fingerprint sensor but is all the
things that they put in there they had
no idea what the outcome would be when
they started they just knew that they
wanted something in Steve's parliament's
that would be insanely great and would
reinvent the category of of phones and
so the willingness to sort of build and
test your way forward is what's the core
principle in
I'm thinking and then when we ported
that over to designing your life it just
makes perfect sense
what's an information interview it's a
prototype of you talking to someone who
might be doing something that you are
interested in doing they're actually you
in your future they've been doing it for
years you've been just you've been just
thinking about what maybe that might be
something I'm interested in having what
we call a prototype interview with
someone and doing it well to get their
story should leave some resonance in you
you'll hear a story that either rings a
bell in your in your heart or your mind
or doesn't and that's a great piece of
information that whether that future
would work for you a prototype
experience going to shadow somebody for
a day during a one-week you know kind of
internship quote internship working on a
project together is a great way to
discover whether that career path or
that activity set or something that
you're interested in so this notion of
building your way for David Kelley says
we build to think we make something so
that we provoke the world say this is a
possible future what do you think and
everybody talks about it and then we get
new ideas is a wonderful way to
prototype your life and it avoids the
possibility that you'll go all-in on
something discovered it's not what you
thought it would be and I'm going to be
disappointed and have to pivot or reset
and that can be pretty costly if you you
know if you're far down the path it's
been wonderful to out and do workshops
on this stuff with the Stanford Alumni
Association I get to meet tons of really
wonderful alums and they all have
wonderful stories some of the cautionary
stories I hear are and it's kind of
paradoxical Wow I'm super successful
I'm partner at the firm again in front
law firm business consulting firm
whatever I'm making you know lots of
money seven figures I'm you know able to
support a fantastic lifestyle for my for
my family and I'm miserable one woman
said to me it feels a little piece of my
soul every day to go to work and I sold
that can't be that doesn't sound healthy
but let's work on that and she said no
you don't understand I'm stuck I'm you
know I'm the youngest woman
the firm the only woman partner the firm
I need to do this you know to uphold
this image I need to do this because
it's because I believe in it but I hate
the work I'm doing
Emily built the lifestyle that requires
you know this kind of money and
everything else and so you know I'm
meeting people in other words that
haven't had a chance to stop on this
they're very successful people obviously
but the success has tracked them into a
situation and a lifestyle that they
never they never wanted they never
thought about it very much they just
sort of went for the next bright shiny
accomplishment because they're smart and
people full of capacity they were
successful in getting the things they
never asked themselves do I really want
this and so the earlier you can start
engaging in this design process and
saying and before I before I decide you
know that being a partner at the law
firm is what I really really want I
probably had to go to shadow a partner
maybe have conversation with a couple of
associates take a few people out to
lunch and dinner somebody must know
somebody who can introduce me to someone
at one of these situations or do I want
to be a professor do I want to be you
know all these things
there's a famous some science fiction
writer William Gibson who I love and
he's got a famous quote the futures
already here it's just unevenly
distributed somebody is you can't know
anything about your personal future but
someone is probably living a very
similar analogous future and they're
already doing it they've been doing it
for years and so they represent a little
piece of view in the future the ability
to learn to prototype your way into
these experiences try things in a really
low threat situation Dave and I say set
the bar low clear it do it again design
these information interviews these
information prototypes and information
expertise experiences to learn how to
imagine your future it's so critical and
the other thing that's true the only
product design I'll do a bunch of
ethnography and research and I'll come
back with a product of everybody in the
group
working with said they wanted and then
I'll show them the new prototype and
then they'll say oh now that we see that
I've changed my mind that's not what I
want anymore
and it's very frustrating as a designer
or an engineer could hear that the kept
cut the customer keeps changing their
mind but what happened in the moment
when I showed them the thing that they
said that they wanted when they actually
realized what is possible what is
possible in this new future of course
they change their mind because their
needs change because now they know
something is possible that they didn't
they could not have a magic and that's
exactly what we want to happen in fact
it's not frustrating it's this notion of
when I go out in the world I engage the
world in radical collaboration with
curiosity to designers mindsets I've
reframed the problem and I'm looking for
people who are living in my future and
I'm talking to them and I'm engaging
them and I'm even prototyping little
versions of what it would be like if I
did that and having the embodied
experience of that and I'm having this
the physical experience and the
intellectual experience of that
something Dave and I call narrative
residence is that story my story do I
hear myself in that one when two tuning
forks are in the same room and they're
on the same pitch you bring one the
other one rings in sympathy so do I have
a sympathetic resonance with the future
that I'm exploring and if I do and if I
find myself yourself to help in states
of flow every once in a while as I work
into this or prototype or build my way
forward but I know I'm on the right
track
anyway I want to leave some time for
questions so let me just kind of hit the
takeaway I believe we have demonstrated
through our research and through the
three or four thousand students that an
on-campus enough that you can in fact
design your life and kind of kind of you
have to because if you don't design it
it's going to get designed for you in
some ad hoc process and then you're just
going to be responding to life rather
than trying to sort of manage it and we
find it for most people passions of
course starting point because 80% of us
don't have one again if you have one
awesome go for it
that'll be a an organizing principle but
you will still prototype interview and
prototype experience your way forward
because you still don't know your future
any better than we do a flow Journal is
one way of noticing flow and energy
engagements
are really important things to notice
it's not the time you spend on something
it's the energy you spend on something
our attention which comes from this
plane three pounds of gooey stuff in our
brain our attention is what consumes our
energy we spend our time and attention
on the things we are talking to
ourselves about so be very very aware of
what you're spending your time and
attention on dave has a phrase and it's
a little bit a little bit maybe trite or
he says if you don't like your reality
change your mind actually it's a phrase
comes from his mentor it's not as easy
as that obviously when you know stuff
will happen in reality we like to say
bias to action because that's the
designers mindset rather than bias the
planning planning is great but there's
an old military expression a plan of
battle survives first contact with the
enemy and I would argue no plan for your
life is going to survive first contact
with reality stuff will happen in
reality you will have to deal with it
things you will find you know things
that things will happen disappointing
things will happen opportunities that
you wanted will not be available to you
so you will have to replan with action
in real time but what you pay attention
to and how you frame those experiences
the positive and the negative ones is
how you will experience meaning in your
life it's not a zero-sum game and that
you're never too late you can reset this
counter at any point and start over with
that I'd like to take a few minutes as
time permits to to ask Bill a few
questions that have come up and we
invite you to submit additional
questions we'll get to as many as we can
in this ten minutes that we have so so
first of all the one one note that we
got from from the audience which I like
is someone said that this last hour has
been a state of flow for them so so I
wondered if I could hear that so I think
one question that came up earlier in in
the webinar which I think is important
to address and kind of an elephant in
the room potentially in as you think
about careers what is the role of money
in the scheme yeah you know this is one
of the most well researched topics in
psychology and positive psychology
particularly you know does money make
you happy how much money do you have to
have in order to be happy and is the
pursuit of money which which you know
can also includes money gives you
capacity to do different things is that
important is that what makes you happy
and particularly for people who are
knowledge workers folks that are working
not on an assembly line where you get
paid by the number of parts you assemble
but by their doing work that's cognitive
work or some other kind of work the
research is very very clear once you
have enough money and enough means that
you're not worried about your bills
you're not worried about you know your
future you can you can save enough money
to make to feel like you'll have what
you need once you have enough income
incremental amounts after that lead to
absolutely no more happiness or sense of
purpose in your life so you know if
you're Warren Buffett
it doesn't matter you've got to a couple
of hundred thousand dollars and you can
live in the house you want to live in
and you can you know do everything else
having a yacht and everything else does
not increase or much happiness at all so
this notion that you can pursue money
for happiness is a really toxic notion
now if you don't have enough or if
you're insecure the flow of money might
be interrupted because your industry is
in turmoil I'm something else those are
all real problems and those you can work
on but there's a thing psychologists
call the hedonic treadmill this hedonism
is a searcher pleasure right and the
hedonic treadmill assists treadmill at
pleasure so I go to work and I'm happy
for a while than I get bored so they I
get a raise in a promotion now I'm happy
again and then about roughly about six
statements later I mean back to the
exact same state of whatever my my my
rest state was and for it so my
conclusion of course as well it was nice
to get a race but it wasn't enough it's
like I had more than I'd be happier so
then I get another raise I get another
promotion
and I end up partner at a law firm I'm
making you know $650,000 base for the 2
million bonus and I'm no happier than I
was when I was the associate and I'm
making $150,000 here exact I'm more
miserable because I have more
constraints on my my behaviors and my
time so it's absolutely clear money it's
not like you're happy you of course have
to be in a position where your safety
security and you know basic needs are
met once that has occurred take money
off the table and go for purpose
Denton dive Dan prize Dan Pink's book
damping so fantastic God that we've done
some work with the written a bunch of
different books within the book driver
attacks about what motivates people to
work hard all the research says its
autonomy mastery and purpose you have
purpose for your work master means
you're learning all the time an autonomy
means here you're deciding how to get
the tasks done that you want it done
doesn't mean you work for yourself just
means you're yours nothing micromanage
if you have those three things money
will money will not make you happy
search for things that actually go yeah
there's another comment that came in
from one of the listeners that said
there are two amounts of money enough
and not enough so I think that's a nice
summary of that other way people who win
the lottery to win millions and millions
of dollars within 18 months go back to
the exact same amount of satisfaction
and happiness in their life it makes no
difference at all if they were a
miserable person they remain miserable
if they were a happy person they remain
happy whatever your set point is money
doesn't change it all right so we're
getting a lot more questions but we'll
pick one I don't think we'll have to
answer more than one question in the
design thinking process there is a lot
of emphasis put on getting feedback and
testing with users testing your
prototypes how do you do that in this
situation you've prototyped a number of
lives or a number of activities and how
you get feedback and maybe related to
that what are some metrics that you use
to evaluate the success of your no
difference so the feedback mechanism is
against empathy for yourself how does
this feel to me I did this little
prototype I shadowed this doctor for a
day or I went and I did a one-week you
know unpaid project with this
how did I feel about that what's my
internal state both my emotional state
my intellectual state that's one that's
one measure and then two how was my work
received it's unlikely that you're going
to be happy and feel like you're
thriving if you are not excellent at the
things you do so you have your own
strengths and weaknesses we all do if
I'm working from my strengths and if the
work product that I deliver is well
acceptable that's exceptional we really
like working with you that I'm getting
two kinds of feedback I enjoy the work
and the people enjoy my output that's in
them in the work to me
but it would it would include any other
domain I mean you're unlikely to be
happy if you're not good at something so
you're looking for where in the world
will the things that I'm strong at be
well-received
and if I'm looking for money for those
things that's in the market place of
them in the world of Art and Design then
it's about having people who appreciate
the quality of my my art or my my work
in that domain so I need the feedback
loop from the world to say oh yeah the
thing that you're doing that you're
really good at we want that to there's
an acceptance on the other side
otherwise you're done you're the unpaid
part of artists in poverty that's fine
you can choose to be that person there's
nothing wrong with that
but you just have to accept that the
world doesn't watch your art most
artists don't care about that problem so
that's okay but if you're planning on
this being something that supports you
and remember this is your vocation and
there's your application vocations what
to do for mining applications what you
do for meaning you may decide to make
those the same thing that's a kind of
modern idea my grandfather who came over
from Wales worked at the National
Biscuit Company Nabisco making cookies
for 40 years you know in the Union
working hard came along his that was
just making money the meaning in his
life was his family he was a member of
the Elks he was a member of you know his
church
that's what that's what drove the
meaning in his life so this notion that
you're gonna get it all in place is a
very modern idea but in any case picks
the place where you want to get the
feedback from and then listen carefully
is the world responding to the things
I'm offering was the second part
allometric yeah that's where the metrics
would be I'm doing my flow Journal I'm
noticing flow states are popping up more
after I'm doing my energy mapping and
I'm noticing that I'm leaving most weeks
with a fairly high energy reserve and
I'm excited and enthusiastic about the
next thing and the other metric is is
the work if you're in the vocation thing
is the world paying me what I think I
need to make in order for this to be
meaningful work for me so as long as you
know I'm getting paid enough you know i
we do run into I'm you know as these
work so I'm a CEO make a lot of money
but you know really want to be a poet I
go great you can get as far as I know
there is nothing stopping you from being
a poet oh no you don't understand I want
to be a poet and I still need to make
seven figures because I got the house
and the Tesla's in mobile and I'm like
okay well that's your gravity problem or
B maybe you should try rap maybe you're
the next you know dr. Dre you don't look
like it to me
frankly but the only seven figure poets
I know right rap music so if you're not
willing to do poetry on the markets
terms and my suggestion is keep your CTO
day job and go out to poetry slams at
night and open mic nights at night and
get your application you know to fulfill
that part of you that wants to speak in
poetic terms but don't don't blame the
world that there are no seven figured
you know seven-figure salaries for poets
because that's just gravity dude great
wonderful so this was very informative
as I said we had lots and lots of
questions and interest all of you will
be receiving a recording of this webinar
within a week so that you can review it
again and and try and practice on these
things and as we mentioned we would love
to see as many of you as are interested
here with us in June to try and get some
additional practice with the design
thinking and designing your life
activities have a very good rest of your
day and thank you for joining us